لماذا أنت واثق جدًا من أنه سيغير
سلوكه السيد الرئيس ،
نعم أنا لست واثقًا
مما تفعله عندما قلت إنني تعرضت للاختراق ،
قلت
ما قلته كان دعونا نفهم الأمر ،
قلت ما الذي سيغير سلوكهم
هو ذلك  يتفاعل معهم بقية العالم
ويقلل
من مكانتهم في العالم ، لست
واثقًا من أي شيء ،
فأنا فقط أقول حقيقة ولكن نظرًا لأن
سلوكه السابق لم يتغير وفي
ذلك المؤتمر الصحفي بعد الجلوس
معك
لعدة مرات  نفى عدة ساعات
تورطه في الهجمات الإلكترونية
، وقلل من شأن انتهاكات حقوق الإنسان ،
حتى أنه رفض ذكر اسم أليكسي نافالني ،
فكيف يتم ذلك في
اجتماع بناء
كرئيس ،
فأنت لا تفهم أنك في
عملك الخاص ،
فأنا مدين بي  السؤال الأخير ، اعتذار ،
لا ينبغي أن أكون رجلًا حكيمًا
مع الإجابة الأخيرة التي قدمتها على
أي حال ، شكرًا لكوني هنا
أنت